and on the other side of the world
catastrophic flooding in pakistan has
killed more than one thousand people you
heard that number correctly one thousand
tire villages have been washed away by
the flood waters and officials say
nearly one million homes have been
damaged or destroyed millions of people
have been displaced there holly williams
shows us the huge scale of the
devastation
these floods are biblical according to
pakistan's government
more than 30 million people have been
inundated in a country already weighed
down by poverty
and pakistan's government says one thing
is certain this is a catastrophe caused
by climate change this is a humanitarian
disaster
of very of of epic proportions
thousands are without shelter many are
without food and people are stranded
more than 2 000 miles of roads have been
washed away according to the red cross
the only way out in some areas is by air
and that's also how food is getting in
we left our homes in a hurry says this
woman some days were able to eat other
days we have nothing
some have made it to safety literally on
their own steam
while desperation has also sparked
ingenuity a daring rescue on a bed frame
rigged up on a zip line
satellite images show a country laid to
waste before the deluge and after
if climate change is the culprit this
year's floods may be just a preview of
pakistan's future
for cbs morning's holly williams london